>> Technology has really moved to the Cloud
wholesale. We've become, you know, the number
one provider of email and collaboration systems
in the U.S. by a pretty fair margin over our
competitors. And that's pretty amazing to
see a market that, three years ago, nobody
was outsourcing, nobody was moving to the
Cloud. And now it's become the dominant way
that schools are delivering these services
to their students. And it's happening in the
Fortune 500, and every day, every week, you
know--not every day, I shouldn't say that.
But every few weeks, we're turning loose another,
you know, 20,000 or 30,000-person company
who is moving all their employees to Google
Apps. And that's something we're doing with
a great record of success. We have not had
companies of that size go back once they go
to the Cloud. So it's a real testament that,
you know, once you go there and you see what
the future looks like, though it's certainly
not perfect today, nobody has any desire to
go back, and I think that's really exciting.
What I want to really say to our partners
that are here today is probably one of the
most common questions I get in the millions
of small businesses, large businesses, schools,
the City of Los Angeles, whatever, you name
all the people that are using Google, and
they say to us, "When is Google gonna do x,
y, or z? When are you gonna build a CRM application?
When are you gonna build a blah-blah?" And
my answer usually is, "Probably never." And
we've really decided a long time ago, you
know, we have to focus our efforts. There
are certain things--really when there's a
consumer analog to this application where
we think we have some degree of expertise
to bring to the situation. And other than
that, we would really rather offer a platform
to others. And I think what you're seeing
today here is really the beginning of that,
a platform where we want to have a lot of
people offering applications in the Cloud
that have some of the sensibilities that we
have about how to, you know, make these applications
useful and integrated. So I think this is
a great start to it. We are very excited.
One of the things that it's gonna let us do
is put more energy toward our existing applications.
And they are certainly far from perfect, so
we have a lot more work to do on those, but
we're excited to push forward the Google Apps
suite, we are very excited to have a lot of
partners in this now to, you know, allow a
business not just to move part of their world
to the Cloud, but to move their entire business
to the Cloud, and I think that's what this
is all about. So we just want to say, first
of all, thanks to everyone who participated.
The partners have been great working with
us to get this as far as we've come. You can
see here the list again. You saw it earlier.
But all the partners that have been involved
with us prelaunch. You can see the URLs. You
can go see the Apps Marketplace hopefully
live as I speak. And it's been a great experience.
I should also say, by the way, there'll be
some sessions related to this at Google I/O
in May in San Francisco. It is unfortunately
sold out. I think Vic is gonna have to look
for a bigger venue next year. But hopefully
a lot of you are already signed up for Google
I/O, and we look forward to take some more
big steps forward with this in May. So thank
you all for coming. And thanks for everybody
who's paid attention and stayed with us online.
And for those who are here at Google, you
can mix and mingle with the Google team and
with partners for a while now. So thanks again.